all right guys
bang bang i have the one and only mr jim
cramer here what's going on man
bob i got to tell you it's one of the
most exciting times of my life because
why
we have an intersection of sports and
of stocks like i've never seen it it
does seem like every game is a
championship game
and uh every uh stock day is a day where
people reconfigure
and say you know what this is the worst
day ever this is the best day ever
so when you get this level of excitement
when you get this level of schizophrenia
what do you want to do you want to call
the biggest schizophrenic in the world
and that's me
i love it all right you know what month
is the most important month
which one may national mental health
month
two years before we get into
uh what you're doing now you have a
whole life
before uh cnbc media etc uh let's just
start with
uh kind of your background um you went
to harvard
you uh spent a bunch of time as a
reporter then at some point you managed
to hedge fund just tell us that story
real quick for those that don't know
okay so uh
i get out of harvard i don't get my
degree of course because i criticized
the guy who gives you the diploma
he just waved me off the stage my folks
you know first generation
my folks were there and they were crying
i didn't get my diploma for a month so i
mean i got a late start
uh then i went home and i was determined
to try to get a job i was rejected by 57
newspapers i kept
every rejection most of those are out of
business i'm still here
uh what i think was really important was
that the phillies were having a great
year
and i i was determined to watch every
single game
i forgot that you have to work so my mom
turned my bedroom into a den
and told me to get the hell out so i
moved to washington with my aunt
worked for congressional quarterly where
i was the key operator
meaning that i had to operate the xerox
machine
then i uh that's true that was my job i
applied to a million papers i ended up
getting
uh hired by the tallest democrat because
uh i don't know it was for 19 000 a year
that seemed like a great amount
and which it wasn't by the way even in
tallahassee
and i get down there and i'm covering
sports and i'm covering
fsu uh baldwin just gotten down there
i tried to do an investigation of the
nca
uh and how they were handling the grade
degradation of the football team
they weren't doing it as well as you
think and i realized that to be a car
i'd be obama under my car so i very
quickly pivoted
and wrote about florida a m and florida
state and then
um i had a terrible break i say terrible
because i ended up living down the block
from where ted bundy killed those girls
uh and i did some reporting that got
some notoriety they got not rarity that
got me hired by the
ellie hill examiner where i i really for
a long time
covered uh homicide not a great beat and
when you're too cynical about it it's
time to move on
then i moved back to new york i was
having some health problems
um that were uh indirectly oh check that
directly related to huge amount of
drinking
um i say that because i had a gigantic
size of greenland mercator projector
yellow stain which i thought could wash
off but my doctor who was a
farmworkers clinic doctor he explained
to me no
jim in order to get rid of that you have
to do something
that you may not want me to do you drink
i said occasionally and i
said wait a minute but i said
occasionally in the morning occasionally
afternoon occasions
so i got my life together and then the
rest is kind of good history went to
harvard law
got hired by goldman uh left to be a
hedge fund manager and then started the
streets.com in 1995.
all right so let's start with uh hedge
fund world uh
while you were doing that what was that
environment like this is like late 90s
into the early 2000s i think right yeah
i left
there were only about 100 hedge funds
when i left goldman i left goldman in
february of 87
uh got it started had a lot of you know
i don't know i had about like 40 million
under management which was a lot then
had a partner we had a tremendous
dispute
uh he left my uh my then
uh girlfriend literally became my wife
and then all became my ex-wife there's a
journey for you
uh i started work with me and told me
right before the crash
of 87 that this market was going to
crash and we went to all the great beers
and they all loved it said no no no no
it's great workers pulled back out by
but we sold everything and because i was
in cash for the crash
uh i had a head start on everybody else
for years because people kept giving me
money saying
well he knew to get out of the crash and
i ended up doing pretty well i made a
lot of money it was fun
gave it most of it to my wife in in the
divorce didn't want to have a big fight
um what can you do i mean that's real
life
uh and start it over it got it
and so what when you say you started
over was this you went and did another
hedge fund or this way you started the
street
that's right well you know at the age of
50 the street had been going on for a
while
um it's when i i did start make money
uh but look i mean divorce is something
people don't talk about
because it's very tough uh and i felt
very sad about it and i speak to cam
spoken account yet today's book
yesterday
but it is um it's very very it's very
very jarring because there's no handbook
uh i ended up marrying someone uh i met
on a blind date about eight months after
i uh broke up
uh there's a terrific article if you
google the new york times it was number
one in the new york times for two
straight days
about how amazing uh lisa detweiler is
it was
our wedding announcement and wedding
announcement got a lot of attention i'm
very proud of that even as i'm not proud
at all about the divorce obviously
absolutely and so tell us the story of
startingthestreet.com because i think
that
you you've been way ahead of a bunch of
these different trends that now
everyone's talking about
uh and by way ahead i mean literally in
some cases 20 years so
tell us that story of uh why you started
it and how and how you guys
kind of built it okay so uh
in 1991 i helped start smart money
and smart money then immediately became
what's the neighbors also jim stewart
the great writer james b stewart
uh and we just had an
unbelievably good time uh
it was one of those things where i
realized that steve schwartz
as swrtz uh was a visionary
and he got us together and said listen i
want to do a magazine
that is about making money in stocks our
first cover is like finding the next
amgen it had
a submarine we were very single stock
oriented as opposed to all these idiots
now dooley's etfs and saints dangers on
single stocks
those people are charles we'll get to
them later um so
we were coming out once a month and i
went to the editor
and i said you know what there's this
thing called the web this is after four
years
and we can come out every day we don't
need to come out in the month and we
don't need any delivery people for
we can go up against even the wall
street journal you don't need trucks you
don't need dead trees you know this
and they says credit dude uh we'll buy
it
from you for four hundred thousand i
said no i mean if you're gonna
buy from phone i'll just go do it myself
so i quit
smart money i took the money i was
making at the hedge fund and i started
uh the street with my friend marty perez
uh and the first thing we did was i said
miami said let's get the best guy
in the world so i went to michael lewis
uh
the great writer he came out to my farm
in pennsylvania
we had a handshake deal and never heard
from him again
and auspicious but then what i did was i
went to
i happened to believe in young
journalists so i went to the editors
of i just looked them all up of every
single major college paper in the
country
and i offered them stock and all of them
today they're all working at great
places like
alex burnson's doing great things and i
oh i i've got
i've got from uh reuters and dow jones
uh
people all over the place who are high
level uh
and are doing great things now that
where they really got to start uh and i
was very proud of the fact that uh even
dan carla russo
who's our editor-in-chief worked there
we had some amazing people over the
years
came public in 1999 one of those
ridiculous
moments where our stock opened at 60 and
then went to one
uh with occasional moments where it
stopped before
uh paul allen put some money in got the
stock up to four five
we had a series of ceo changes
um and kind of went to hell uh
got some money again from tcv which is
the first investor in netflix
and they're fantastic guys uh and that
really didn't work out because it came
in at 14 that was the level
uh stockton went all the way back down
again because we kept
being advertising oriented ultimately
became subscription oriented
and that's where the money is people
didn't realize that
a lot of rancor a lot of ugliness uh
not good a lot of heartache uh was it
worth it
here's what i say i gave hundreds of
people healthcare insurance
and so therefore it was worth it that's
what i did
and i'm proud of that anything else no
i am proud that a lot of people got
health care insurance
and that that is the best thing pomp
that i do
that's awesome and so obviously you've
been ahead of two trends right so one is
the subscription uh kind of media trend
where you guys recognize that fairly
early
uh and then the second is uh kind of
this personality or
what is now being called creator driven
uh content so let's start with the
subscription first
uh you really it sounds like came up
with the subscription revenue out of
necessity because the advertising
revenue just kept being so uh kind of
lumpy and so much fluctuation right hey
man i mean it went from like 26 million
to 12 million
uh we were desperate i quit the hedge
fund
again rank or sadly i
pre-medication a lot of rancor uh and
then
i realized look if we don't have a
subscription revenue
uh based on personality as you said
we're not gonna make it so i started
doing uh
we had doing real money which people
paid for none of the venture capitalists
want us to do that but it was only real
revenue
and i realized i was writing on real
money and people kept reading this one
column
where i was offering action alerts you
would get an
action alert on real money get red arrow
and people would then say jim i wish we
knew
more about those so i started action
alertsplus.com which is our by far the
biggest money maker that we have
i fought a lot of the ceos over uh
having a subscription model i one time
even
tried to buy the subscription business
from a ceo who will remain nameless
um and in all times there was tremendous
tension
at all times uh and it was kind of like
a jail it was a jail where i ended up
making a lot of money i admit that
but um it's the subscription business is
a bear because you got to be there every
minute
i'm very lucky to have jeff marks at
fema to back me up um we have the
we turned into a club that was important
because we can't tend to do what we'd
like to do
uh because of the restrictions after
cnbc for the chapel trust so we offer a
club we offer
uh different recommendations you have to
know your suitability but mainly we try
to teach you these people who are robin
with people the 13 million strong
they should all i mean i was trying to
figure out do i do a skinny version for
them
because they desperately need the
education that we provide
i'm very proud of the club even though
it's probably the biggest time
consumer i have other than mad money
talk a little bit about i know that
you're very big on the financial
literacy right just the the absolute
lack of financial education that both
our schools have
uh but then ultimately what ends up our
population talk a little bit just about
that problem and kind of how you see
getting fixed
well one of the things that just
absolutely drives me crazy
is that the irrelevance of the vast
majority of things i learned
and i was thinking today i don't know
why i was thinking about
my biology class in eighth grade i mean
you know we cut up a lot of frogs
i mean if we cut up a lot of dollar
bills we would have been smarter
it is incredible to me how little people
know i mean frog legs versus fibers
there is without a doubt a dying
desire for people to make money with
what they see whether it be amazon would
be facebook whether it be snap whether
it be
uh twitter uh whether it be alphabet you
know
there's just they want to make money and
they want to make money in individual
stocks
that's different from this long
progression we have from individual
stocks
all the way to indexing i think that's
peak and now we're back to individual
stocks again
and you know i just i i struggle
i i struggle because what i see is
people making the same
mistakes that i saw in 1980 1990
2000 2010 now they're doing 2020
they play with their hearts they don't
know what they own
and i'll give just one really good
educational tip that's worked for me
before you buy a stock give me three
reasons
why you would now see what happened is
the electronic
e-trading made it so that people we
didn't have to ever talk about a stock
to just buy a stock so a lot of people
buy
the vaxstorks whatever it is they're
sorrentos
um and there was a great city in italy
and they end up completely
uh getting killed because when the stock
goes down they don't know what they
bought so then they sell so
my number one educational uh suggestion
is
if you have the time and inclination you
can buy individual stocks but you better
know what you're buying
or else you really do have to default
and just try to save over time with an s
p
index button but it is just terrible how
little education that's why people keep
borrowing money
to buy stocks i don't mind borrowing
money to buy a house because you live in
it
but when you borrow money to buy stocks
and the stocks go down or the options go
down
you're out of luck and you're and
therefore you're even though i'm jimmy
chill
you're stupid i mean try to get you me
i i love jimmy not chill but we'll take
jimmy chill today that's fine
thank you uh in terms of the kind of
creator or
um uh brand as an individual right
obviously mad money
people know you you've on there every
single day
punching buttons about 30 400 shows
3 400 shows wow hey i'm quinn
so help us understand where did the idea
come from
in terms of making you the personality
to drive all the media
and content start from radio all right
real money started in 2001 why
because we needed to make more revenue
for the street i gave the revenue to the
street
i would introduce our writers uh the
opening was a monologue
and then i did the danger zone then i
took calls
uh i did a lightning round that's where
the lightning round came from
and then i do an educational piece and
then i would do what's coming up today
or later in the market it ran in a whole
lot of radio markets was a very big
success
it started out uh kind of a minor
network
and then it went to bloomberg he used to
run it three times they
loved it and then we switched to cbs
which was fabulous
and i did radio and tv i did real money
and then went over to mad money
until i got nodes in my throat i was
using 15 i was saying 15 000 words a day
that's too many i wrote i got a doctor's
note that i gave to les mundes but that
point was not disgraced
and said listen he can't do the show
anymore lest let me out of the contract
and i now just do tv but the tv show is
the radio show on tv
got it and did you have a sound board
for the radio show yes that's where it
came from
uh i had a fabulous producer by the name
of dave gorad
who runs talk for for serious satellites
is a genius and he came up with
lightning round
he came back up with am i diversified he
came up with the format of this
opening and then he came up with the
idea that you have to be educating
educating educating so we have that big
educating financial literacy block
uh the radio show i like this radio show
very much because
i happen to love dave and we had a lot
of rhythm but when
i i was about to leave uh cnbc
uh because i wanted to do the mad money
and they
the ceo laughed at it and thought it was
stupid got a news
ceo jeff zucker he listened to the radio
and said hey i want this on tv
and a month later we had it on tv right
after uh the eagles lost the super bowl
uh because uh was at their um uh adam
mcnabb
threw up in the count of seconds there
was dylan
did you prefer television or radio in
doing the show
i got the face for rating i think that's
important
i i still can't believe that people
would like watch me it's frightening
um but i absolutely love tv because i'm
surrounded by amazing people
tv radio is a very solo experience
people don't realize how solo it really
is when you're sitting there
with the headphones in the microphone
you know like you're just going
tv i've got this tremendous supporting
group i got a great executive producer
i have a stage manager i have all these
great people in the control room
i've got all these people on the floor
running with cameras all of them of
course in my fantasy football league the
slump and ditka fantasy league
and they're all my friends i've got
great i've got my
head writer is also my only writer
that's my nephew cliff
mason who is my sister's kid he started
as a high schooler we got all the other
writers fired when he decided to go to
college
he wrote the show ends in college he
writes all the written pieces um
i drew the top though and it's just a
it's an
unbelievable support network of people
who love each other and it's all that
uh led by regina gilgan the executive
producer who has built a team
unlike any other i like team sports and
i like the team that we put together
and they make it possible if they
decided they didn't want to play anymore
that'd be very hard for me
absolutely how important is it that you
had the experience as a hedge fund
manager
uh for all the stuff that you're doing
in the media side it's evident
uh because i know
that what i say is based on real life
mistakes i made in real life good things
that i did i used to keep a shoebox
in my closet of all my bad trades and
every month i would review it and curse
it myself
and look at what i did wrong and it
enabled me to be right that's why i
spent a
gigantic amount of time talking about
what you do wrong because if you do
things wrong
and you don't note them and figure them
out you're not going to change
doing things right well that's just yeah
that's fine you don't need to worry
about that
but doing things wrong that is sinful
and i spent a lot of time in my book
real money describing all the sins that
i committed
and i think it's very important for
people to recognize that the winds take
care of themselves
it's the losses that wreck you so you've
obviously talked a lot about the things
you did wrong
was this a hey we did really well as a
hedge fund but we had mistakes and i
talked about the mistakes or is this
no we sucked at the hedge fund and i
talked about all the mistakes
well we um we compounded it 24
after all fees versus the s p being at 8
so we tripled the s p i know that there
were lots of people
who were um uh skeptical about my
numbers
uh only not about the actual numbers but
skeptical
because because uh i did not run
billions i ran uh 500 million and
that was a lot of money to me i mean hey
wasn't my money it was other people's
money
but i kept all my money in the fund and
i was able to to make a lot of money
because i was betting on myself
uh i didn't love it uh i hated myself
i did not uh comport myself well
um i was physical in
the way that i handle myself a kind of
like an eagles fan on a bad day
and i was uh not the person that i
wanted to be
and there was an intervention done in
november of 2000 by my best friends and
my family
to get me to quit i was i weighed about
35 more pounds than i do now
uh i was very i was very worried about
my heart i didn't work out
uh and it was time for change uh but we
made a lot of money in the interim
and again uh what i did was i said look
you have to work if you work for me it's
a bargain with the devil
uh you're going to work six days a week
you can pick i don't know some people
have to be sunday some people
didn't want to work saturday but you
have six days a week and you must be in
at 6 a.m and you leave when i tell you
and you must never ever ever come in
later than 6 a.m
or else you're late and there are a lot
of people who didn't understand that and
there was a guy i'll leave it leave his
name out because he's
just a repulsive figure um but he came
in at 601 and i threw a water bottle out
of them told me to get that
while i i was much more into f bomb sim
um
now i'm jimmy cho throwing water bottles
is better than most eagles fans they
would throw batteries
yeah i know i threw a snowball in santa
but i didn't hit them
uh batteries are very effective hey that
which brings me to dave portnoy is
constantly talking to me about the
batteries and philadelphia give me a
break
we threw we threw
punches that's what we were good at and
other fans because we're like the worst
drunks in the world now this uh i know
that you know
krypto and i follow um portnoy very
closely and i love what he says he's
always talking about you talk about
the suits and how they don't know what
they're talking about and they
discourage people and that's very much
all i like he's a
he's not a teacher so much as he is a
pundit
now he got all in i can see i got this
house at the beach from back up
and it's on the synagogue and right
across from it are these finger vi
the binkle reed the binkle finkle wiggle
vine
yeah they made like a trillion a
trillion dollars in crypto
and i know that they follow just like
the president's son
everybody follows portland it's insane
uh
and they haven't gone on the crypto and
and and
porter was making a fortune that's what
i understood and then he leaves crypto
now you know crypto what the hell
happened so
uh dave i think is and we'd have to ask
him for sure but my understanding is
that in 2017 would be
what i said we have to put words in
dave's mouth
in 2017 bitcoin was going up you know
from a thousand to twenty thousand that
year
and uh there's a bunch of people at
barstool who started buying bitcoin and
basically they were
you know talking [ __ ] to him saying hey
look i'm making all this money you idiot
and so he bought bitcoin and then did
this epic video that's now famous
of uh he's like i just bought bitcoin i
don't know what bitcoin is but i'm not
gonna sit around while everyone else
gets rich and i don't get rich if
everyone else is getting rich on bitcoin
i'm getting rich on bitcoin
so he goes on this whole thing obviously
bitcoin crashes uh a bunch of people
lose money
uh and he he doesn't really talk about
it for a number of years and then just
recently when he started getting into
all the stocks and everything
uh the one thing that crypto's really
good at is there's a bunch of people on
the internet who've got memes and gifts
and
tweets and they're ready to rock and
roll and so they've been chirping at
them non-stop to stop playing around
with stocks and go buy crypto
so eventually he got the winklevi to
come they tried to explain to him you
know here's what bitcoin is whatever
here's the best part is he put some
money into uh into crypto and you know
one of the things i like about dave is
that uh when he does something he
doesn't just kind of dip his toe in he
jumps all in you know
basically naked right off of the cliff
and uh put you know
my understanding is a couple hundred
thousand if not a couple million bucks
in
and uh it's super volatile so it goes up
you know eight ten percent
green hammer's out he's ready to rock
and roll he loves crypto
well when it goes down eight or ten
percent you know he says hey
stocks only go up crypto goes down i'm
out i'm out of crypt i'm going back to
play with stocks
okay so let's say that he actually
wanted to do it in a serious fashion
what would he need to know before he did
buy
yeah here's the whole pitch i think
right now is if you look at bitcoin
specifically
the two things that are important to
understand is the macro environment
there's no better asset in the world
than bitcoin in terms of
you've got interest rates manipulated
down to zero you've got trillions of
dollars being printed
uh which creates a fear of inflation
whether it ever happens or not
retail is going to rush for inflation
hedge assets inflation hedge assets can
include everything from real estate
precious metals bitcoin etc
and bitcoin structurally it's the
smallest market cap it's got the most
volatility
is likely to go up the most in value
when people fear inflation
right so if you look at like a paul
tudor jones when he comes out and he
says look inflation hedge assets are
going to do great in this macro
environment
it's just bitcoin's going to be the
fastest horse right so they'll all do
well
just bitcoin's gonna be the most
volatile so when it goes down that means
bitcoin draws down the most
but when all these assets go up bitcoin
goes up the most but i mean
let me think i mean there's a stock okay
called back okay yep um this symbol is
gold
i like that because it's easy portland
must like that is i want to buy gold
even goes by gold
and i think gold is remarkable and this
company has an incredibly low cost
that gold is they make about 700 per
ounce
um does gold complement crypto or does
crypto make it so you don't need gold
so the way i think about take like a
gold bug and a bitcoiner you put them
side by side
yeah they agree almost to the t
on all of the structural problems the
macro environment
uh all those issues they agree on the
theoretical solution which is
sound money principles right what they
disagree on is the application of the
sound money principles
so you can do that through a digital
means which is bitcoin right or you can
do that through more of an analog
means which is gold what most bitcoiners
would argue is if you put gold and
bitcoin next to each other from a
utility standpoint
bitcoin is more efficient it's more
divisible it's more portable it's got
kind of all these advantages right
and there's an entire generation of
people kind of
35 and under 40 and under whatever
they're choosing
bitcoin because it is a digitally native
asset versus gold which is kind of the
boomer
sound money principle asset well they're
both gonna they're both gonna do well
they're both going to do well it's just
what's going up more you're exactly
right
i i see the fluidity of gold and gold
stocks and glt
i tell people if they can and this is
where i think that you've got the edge
on me
go buy bullion put it in a safety
deposit box which you have to pay for
uh give keys to your kids and remember
that you can take bullion if you have to
or gold coins
uh choose the next place you have to go
but there's a big vig for gold coins
costs a lot and the bullion's heavy and
very bulky
and you can't just walk around with it
uh so yes you're right
my curiosity about crypto is uh if i had
this
no if i were more secure in it i would
say okay look uh
younger people you may not like the
analog you feel maybe feel more
comfortable with the digital
i totally understand people want to buy
you know people want to dig a hole in
the backyard and put gold
well forget it i mean you know the guy
the guys who cut your logo find it um
so i feel very strongly that i have
missed crypto
i haven't missed gold uh i have my
father buy a lot of gold
uh you go overseas you can put your gold
in if you in 1933
uh the government confiscated over
called the people and that was foreign
fdr um so i how do i know
i read these stories you know about
someone forgets the code or they
lose it and and then i start thinking
well that's too scary for me uh
was that just a phony incident and also
can can the cyber uh
attackers like i like z scale or i like
crowdstrike
i like palo alto and they always tell me
that people are hacking
uh crypto or also they tell me that you
got to pay
ransomware in crypto so therefore you
better get better find out about crypto
so
obviously there's more uses but give me
a security story
yeah so if you think of gold right you
can own gold everything from own
barrick gold which is a company that
that's in that business
you can own uh gold that somebody else
holds for you
right you can go own the physical gold
and put it in your house or you can own
gold and put in a safety deposit box and
have kind of the
most extreme severe security set up in
the world right
same thing same thing with bitcoin in
the sense of there's many different ways
to get exposure right so you can go
today and you can simply uh use uh
gbtc right grayscale bitcoin trust uh
and you can get exposure
to the actual underlying asset right you
can
actually buy bitcoin and you can hold it
in a custody provider so there's
everything from
uh block fi coinbase you know kraken
gemini all these guys have kind of
uh institutional grade custody providers
then you can actually buy bitcoin and
you can take possession of it yourself
most bitcoiners are going to argue that
you should take possession yourself they
like to sell sovereignty they like the
security
all that kind of stuff well if you're in
here yeah well so you can have a
hardware device
you can hold it on a wallet on your
phone there's again there's a whole
spectrum of ways to own it
what i always tell people is if you know
yourself and you say there's no way that
i know anything technical
you can just go buy and get exposure in
a stock ticker right you can just buy
gbtc
if you say hey you know what i want to
go kind of level two i can buy actual
bitcoin on one of these exchanges and
put it into an institutional grade
custody provider
well gbtc is like gld exactly for
bitcoin
really it's eleven dollars it's 11 uh
there's a premium why wouldn't people do
that is there a thing there
there's a premium uh and it can get kind
of nasty um
at certain like in a really really
obviously frothy times with bitcoin it
can it can go up but
again if that's the exposure you want
right then you can just do it there so
it's kind of a spectrum of control
but i think the the bigger thing here
when you compare bitcoin and gold
you'll like this i think which is with
gold if i said to you
you know how much gold is in the
circulating supply you'll give me kind
of a really
close 51 every year so it's incredibly
healthy the shortage of gold right now
is extraordinary
yeah and you'll but you'll tell me a
pretty close estimate of what the
circulating supply is you'll tell me a
pretty close estimate to the incoming
daily supply
i think part of what the younger
generation is realizing with bitcoin
is everything is provably scarce so one
of the big differences between gold and
bitcoin is
right now you know there's some guy
somewhere who's uh
digging through his field all of a
sudden he finds a gold deposit right
it's not going to move the market
materially but it increases
the gold supply right and nobody knows
and there's a latency of information all
that kind of stuff
with bitcoin everything is provable on
chain so
i know every single day and i can prove
to you
that 900 bitcoin are getting created
each day then i can
prove to you on chain exactly 18 000 or
18 million 400
you know 60 000 bitcoin exists in
circulating supply
and so it's this weird world of like i
know that gold is
scarce i just don't know like to the t
how many ounces exist
right nobody knows having that
provability i think that the younger
generation just because they're
digitally native say
hey that's really attractive i can
actually point to an exact number
and audit it myself because it's
transparent
but what happened to all the um what
happened to all the
the mining i mean nvidia which is stock
i love
they were making cards that people were
used for mining it seems like
that business went away so there's two
different types of uh ways to mine right
so if you've got
uh bitcoin they're using asic miners so
think of these as
specialized computers just all right so
just for uh for bitcoin money
there's also a bunch of people who are
using
um the kind of graphics cards that you
would use for gaming or other types of
things
yep but they're not mining bitcoin
they're actually mining ethereum and a
bunch of other
tokens are they jackasses uh no i mean
look
it's uh think of mining as just a data
center business
but the difference between mining and a
data center business right
is the data center business you got to
have a sales force you got to go out and
find customers with mining you have a
100
persistent customer demand for 100 of
your
uh computing power because all you're
doing is you're renting your computing
power to an algorithm
and that algorithm is paying you 100 24
7 you don't need a sales force
so the unit economics on mining compared
to a traditional data center is much
more attractive
so look what happened why i mean my
stepson one day came to me he said
listen i want to mine
oh okay so that was when it was at 19
000. so exactly everybody was admired
okay so let me ask you this let me ask
you a theoretical question
all right if i were
coming out of college no no no if i was
32
35 and it started to make money and felt
like on my principle which is that you
need 10
of your assets and gold i've been a gold
bug all my life
do you think that i wouldn't even be
thinking about gold and i would just be
thinking i need 10
of my assets and a great hedge against
inflation so i need to be in crypto and
the gold would be something
that actually didn't compute because who
wants to have hide something in some
place and pay for a deposit box
it's really an inefficient way
to to fight inflation yeah i think the
first key and we talked about the
financial education is people are waking
up to just hey i should have an
inflation hedge asset in my portfolio
right
absolutely there's a bucket there i
gotta have it the way that i talk about
it
is each individual person so age income
level
goals all the optimizations are really
hard to kind of give you know one size
fits all advice
right obviously what i do know is the
zero exposure to bitcoin's the wrong
answer so i don't know if it's one
percent five percent 10
right each person's different but
getting off zero percent
is really really important because what
it does is
gold and bitcoin while they both serve
as inflation hedge assets
bitcoin has a very very different return
profile meaning that it's much more
asymmetric
so right now if you look earlier this
year right remember the volatility works
both directions so when
equities drew down 30 in march gold was
down 12 to 15
bitcoin drew down at on one day 50
percent
i mean it you know it's just a nasty a
rip your face off right yeah
dude now when we go the other direction
and asset prices increase
bitcoin's the best performing asset so
bitcoin's up like 45
year-to-date right gold's up about i
think it's 15 to 20
equities are you know flat to kind of
single digit positive in some of the
indexes
and so what you start to realize is if
asset prices are going to go up and the
fed's going to continue to just inject
trillions of dollars of liquidity and
kind of all this macro stuff happens
you just want to have exposure to the
most asymmetric asset
right so i don't think bitcoin will ever
go to zero so your downside may be
you know again 20 30 40 50 whatever it
is
but your upside is hundreds of percent
if not thousands of percent
that brings me to here's the most
important thing you've got to know about
bitcoin
the having so no one's explained this
yet there's something called the bitcoin
having
right and i'm gonna tell you why this is
important i publicly in
uh december of 2018 came out and i
issued a million dollar my partners and
i issued a million dollar challenge
to any manager on wall street they could
pick any asset
any individual stock any asset for a
decade bitcoin will outperform it
million bucks goes to charity knock
yourself out not one person took it
here's why because the bitcoin having
is a programmatic decrease in the
incoming supply
so imagine if in 2008 when gold went
down 30 percent
the government steps in they printed a
bunch of money everyone ran to gold
went up 200 hits an all-time high in
2011. imagine when everyone ran to gold
if 50 of the incoming supply of gold
got taken out of the market so 50 of the
miners just shut down
of course the price would explode right
that's what happened with bitcoin so
in march liquidity crisis occurs
government steps in starts printing
money everyone runs for inflation hedge
assets
bitcoin being one of a bunch on in early
may
there was a drop from each day 1800
bitcoin being created
to now each day there's only 900 being
created
and that happens every four years so
that'll go on for four years 900 a day
get created
and then it'll get dropped to 450 after
that four year period
so programmatically what you see is
you're actually making the asset more
and more scarce over time
but it just so happens that this last
one occurred
at the exact macro environment where
everyone's rushing for inflation hedge
assets and so i actually think bitcoin's
price is going to
top 100 thousand dollars by the end of
next year see i have to say i'm not
going to disagree with that and the
reason why i've been focused on it and
they give me the education on it
i stand drucker miller is a friend of
mine and he's a great investor
though he is a steeler fan which then
causes complications although i have
juju
uh simon schuster there i always call
him simon
but here's the problem he said yesterday
that in three to five years we're all
going to have to pay for what the
government
and uh my friend joe kearney asked me
that and i said i have been
so possessed by that because i know
that we're going to get hurt so when i
go to my inflation handbook what it says
is buy gold
buy masterpieces and buy mansions those
are the three things
that that's it my age okay those are the
three things you had to do now my wife's
in real estate so we've gone with the
real estate as our hedge all right
what we didn't have in that menu was
crypto and i think that you have to have
i'm going to say still say gold recruit
because i have so much gold but
you have to have one or the other and i
like what you're saying about crypto i'm
not in
remember i'm not in gold for the
appreciation i'm in the go i'm in gold
for the alternative
but i don't know how my kids are going
to pay down what happened
uh i i think we had to do it to avoid
the depression so i'm glad we did it
but i see the dollar going down and most
importantly i i know that no one wants
to raise taxes in this country
and even if we did raise taxes we still
can't afford it
we're not cutting social security we're
not cutting medicare
we're on a collision course where which
makes me feel great about the gold i own
but i do feel that it's perfectly
logical to add crypto
to the menu um and now after speaking to
you i think
that my kids when they get my
inheritance
won't feel comfortable with gold and
will feel comfortable with crypto
and i don't want them i want it i try to
put everything i own on one piece of
paper
they want to understand the deposit
boxes to say toronto dominion okay
but they would understand crypto and i
have to start recognizing
that maybe i am using um
maybe i am using a typewriter well
here's what i'll tell you is if you take
ten percent of your gold position right
so just whatever you have
allocated for your uh inflation hedge
bucket
if you take ten percent of that bucket
so let's say you've ten percent in gold
you just take one percent of your
portfolio right ten percent
okay take one percent you put it in
bitcoin
that one percent of bitcoin will
outperform the nine percent of gold over
the next 18 months
hands down not even close and you want
me to actually do the bit
let my kids set up the bitcoin for me
yeah i'll do it
i'll help you do it whoever will help
you do it it's super simple and what you
end up doing is you would end up owning
one percent
bitcoin right in your portfolio if it
goes to zero
you lost one percent not the end of the
day right not happy but not into that no
but that's okay
i i have stuff in it i have an
international uh fund that's done
terribly until now and
i just said look i i can't have all my
eggs in u.s basket
i want to have like i said i got to i i
lost the masterpieces to my
ex-wife god lovers some beautiful
paintings hey man they're totally
tracked they're not gonna
um and but then i have the um i i have
the gold
uh i have the the so-called mansion the
real estate equation okay
and what i do is i need and i'm not a
you know a paid spokesman for why i need
gold or why i need crypto
but i just need something that my kids
will understand as i head to inflation
and they will never understand gold and
the reason why they'll never understand
gold
is they think gold's dangerous it's
dangerous because it can be stolen
it's dangerous because they don't want
to take it out of the bank uh it's
dangerous because
they may forget where it is okay i mean
you know let's say i freedom people talk
about like my crypto
gets hacked or whatever you know what's
really bad is when your kids can't find
your goal and that is by the way not
unusual
so this is why i am fixated on
needing to own crypto uh because
i fear massive amount of inflation and i
don't have
you know gold do okay and the houses
will do okay those are going to keep me
running in place as opposed to pulling
off a cliff the idea of actually
making money well holy cow i take a shot
at that with one percent
think think about this so one thing is
important right is when you talk to
your kids about it you got to make sure
it's bitcoin not just crypto in general
because bitcoin specifically has the
inflation hedge uh things that we're
talking about here
uh the other ones you know advantages
disadvantages but bitcoin specifically
is this kind of inflation hedge
type asset the thing that i would say
is uh that people forget when they hear
this though becomes a very attractive
60 40 global portfolio over the last
five years or so about 7.2 percent
return right annually right if you had
taken
one percent of your assets and put it in
bitcoin even with all the crazy ups and
downs everything
you would have taken that seven point
two percent and gone to nine point two
so it added 200 basis points of
performance annually
right if that one percent had gone to
zero you'd gone from seven point two to
seven percent
so 20 basis point downside 200 bases
point upside so it's literally 10 to 1
in terms of risk reward
right right the key is the standard
deviation of risk
stays about the same and the sharp sharp
ratio goes up over 20 percent
really because it's a non-correlated
asset over long periods of time now i'm
correlated asset you're so right
now let me ask you a very obvious
question for you but not for me
okay um will
my kids understand where it's kept
i mean is it an app so the way to think
about this is uh
wherever you buy stocks the way that
your kids are going to
get access to that is either through a
will or
you're going to have to tell them
username password all that kind of stuff
right same thing here so if you don't
self-custody it meaning that you
actually take physical possession you
know sovereign possession
what you would have to do is let's say
that you use uh gemini the winklevoss
thing right you can go on set up an
account got a username and a password
you buy uh bitcoin you can hold it in
there you have a custody
solution right and then you just got to
make sure that your kids or
whoever oversees the will or whatever
knows how to get access to that account
right the exact exact same thing about
this is i i have trust with my kids and
they're
and they're laddered you know when they
turn 30 when they turn their boat into
a 29-26 and i have stock for that
index funds because not an individual
stocks and i am thinking
that when they turn 35 and turn 40 i
would look i hope i'm there but you
never know right
uh i would love to have right now
some bitcoin in there but i'm worried
what they'll do is they'll read the will
say like where's the bitcoin what does
that do what did he do he made it
like high and dry i don't have the code
i know the code i just lost it someone
hacked it
i want them to feel comfortable when
they turned 35 and 40 that i didn't buy
them something that doesn't exist
yep the exact same thing i mean look as
long as you've got uh
in an account where you want to pass it
on you just gotta have
uh them have the information on how to
get in the account now
when square tells me that they'll handle
trades would can you keep it at square
or you really want to use like the
gemini
uh you can keep it on any of these
exchanges one of the things that you're
just doing right just like any other
um kind of financial institution is
you're just offloading
some of the risk to that financial
institution so you've got to underwrite
their security
their solvency all that kind of stuff
the key piece is
the bitcoin ethos right that the
hardcore bitcoiner
is all about self-sovereignty so just
like you say hey go get the gold and put
it
in you know your backyard or put it in a
safety deposit box whatever
bitcoiners have the same ethos one of
the challenges for people who
are older or not as technical is that
there's a somewhat technical process
to take physical control of a digital
asset right
and so what i always tell people is like
get started by
getting off zero percent exposure so get
to one percent right
hold it in uh one of these kind of you
know well-known
uh large custody providers to start then
mentioning that gemini i know you don't
take any money gemini is the one that
that darian the wiggle voss twins
that that's their exchange right so you
don't want to make fun of they're
actually great guys they belong to a
club that i belong to and
they're incredibly kind and upstaired
and i see them
i don't want to be making fun of it but
if you tell them if you tell them that
we talked
and you're going to buy bitcoin they'll
be your best friend hey
you know they like my wife you know
she's the head of the entertainment
committee
at the club who we belong to and i i
need to do this for my kids
i need to do it because they are uh
much more at risk than i am because of
what happened
let's say before this okay before
february before the pandemic
well i would have said you know why the
stocks are doing well
i feel like they're a good hedge against
inflation there's no inflation
but then everything broke down and now i
know i'm being reckless
i was being prudent with cash okay
that's what i thought
because you have stock you have cash
that's great for your kids remember the
29-26
after what happened during this period
it's not right i know now i went from
being prudent
to being reckless so do i have to go buy
them paintings again very hard and
subjective okay
real estate again taking care i've taken
care of that asset
but i think that they will be by went by
the time they're 35 and 40
much more comfortable owning not the
gold that they have
but the bitcoin that they have because
they're digital
and i am analog i love that it's you
know and look i have no regrets
that's who i am and i've loved gold and
there's a lot of people who hated gold
the whole time i've loved it
and i've loved it before exactly what
you've been talking scarcity value i
like the touch of it
but the touch of it is no longer as
valuable as the scarce
that's the one that i like and as long
as you're telling me
that jim this is something that you can
put and you can tell your kids
they will not be baffled by it they will
not be scared that's really important
because i was concerned that they would
be
that they're going to understand it
better than you will just because
they're digitally native
right which is which is crazy here
here's the best part about bitcoin ready
this is why portnoy
loves uh crypto in general so much is
because
not only is the asset great but the
community
they are the best memes and gifts and
tweets etc on the internet
thanks of course i think so if you
ordered
us you know her whole rap is to do
incredible
instagram and she takes photos of
of food she takes i have another
daughter who is just
me loves the meme of me going like this
they all
understand um and when i tell them about
look there's this deposit box
at this bat and like they're like dad
what it what two keys like in the movies
and what
and do i have to go and like what
everyone will see me in that room and
when they know that i walk out of it
they'll know that i have it and you know
gold coins when you tell me that you're
buying a dollar gold coin for 52
and i don't get that at all because i
did that too i bought gold coins
and i know it's just incredibly
inefficient uh
and i'm possessed by this which is why i
you know tell them listen you can go buy
a gold fund the junior gold fun i'm
allowed to do that
but i i know that i'm being reckless now
i know that when i saw that i was you
know when we got to talk
i talked with my wife about this i said
look i gotta breach this thing that
i'm not comfortable with i'm just not
and she goes well is that really good
important money magic
why don't you educate yourself and i
said well look i'm going to ask this guy
pop i mean i was going to go to portnoy
i was because yeah i mean i said okay
he's in there i got to figure this out
and then he turned on them and yeah and
i'm thinking about
seven years uh uh
seven years 15 years and 20 years
and i know that i am if i just have that
cash in there and some gold
that i they may look back and say why
what was my father
thinking why didn't he know about this
he was supposed to be such a savvy guy
and i think the answer is because i'm
scared but you know
i need i like this idea that the
community is behind you
i like the fact that um this gemini is
somebody you trust and i
have to do my work obviously in the
others you know what of course would be
the easiest is like if
you know if jp morgan uh which i have i
just told jp morgan unless i want to buy
some bitcoin but they i
they won't do that so jp morgan hasn't
done it yet i'm sure they will at some
point but
fidelity has a very funny reality all
right so fidelity has a very big
digital asset business and uh one of the
things that they're doing is basically
helping a bunch of their clients get
into bitcoin right so whether they can
help me
uh i think so yeah they can basically
they can i have most of my money up to
dollars
oh then there you go yeah they can
absolutely help i'll enter
when we get done i'll introduce you to
uh to somebody over there who can uh who
can help you do it well that would be
great i mean
look i when we got a little sidetracked
here but the reason i want to stay with
this education idea
because that's what i'm about i'm a faux
educator if i don't know bitcoins you
know for a long time and people say
well how about bitcoin and i said well i
don't trade
uh coffee and i don't trade cotton
and i don't trade bitcoin and that
sufficed for a very long time
uh it it worked until
the three trillion dollar package
because we don't have that
we don't have three trillion in this
country you can raise them you make the
rich pay as much as you want this is the
first time in my life
and i've said it publicly that i know we
don't have the money
and i that's one of the reasons why i
like gold so much but like you said
how about upside yeah i don't i don't
used to
look when you buy insurance on a car you
don't expect you know you don't
like you have a church on a toyota and
then you get paid for lamborghini it
doesn't work like that
you get paid for the toilet and you're
thrilled you're thrilled
i would love it if i put insurance on
the toyota and i got the lamborghini
uh with a little bit of downside maybe
they don't get as nice a toyota
and so this is what i've been and it's
what literally what i said this morning
on
on spoke on the street which is that i
know it ends badly not the stock
i can tell you to die i'll find you the
next in video whatever my
my kids can't you know they do i mean
they
later on they can do stock but i can
find the nvidia
but i can't find the cash and the cash
is what i'm most worried about
because i know that cash is something
that will be looked at as laziness
and will be looked at as i didn't pay
attention to my kids
the the best thing that you're going to
see and you've probably seen this chart
before
is uh if you go back to 1971 and you uh
take the u.s stock market denominated in
dollars
it's like a perfect line up at 45 degree
angle to the right right
it just looks like great compounding
growth if you denominate
the same exact stock market in gold
it's down right so the stock market's
down denominated in gold
it's just the dollar is being devalued
which again that
that is what is happening and the bottom
50 that are
uneducated about this stuff right
they're the ones who get hurt the most
because they live paycheck to paycheck
they just have cash sitting in their
accounts all
stuff but for those that can educate
themselves
you got to get into these inflation
hedge assets right and so
gold is gonna be just fine like it's not
a gold's gonna do bad
it's just that bitcoin is going to be
way more volatile and over very long
periods of time
i think if don't quote me on this but if
i remember correctly bitcoin's
compounded annual growth rate is over 35
okay right so it's just it just
continues to
be volatile but you need volatility to
go up right
would you do this here's why i own
stocks i tell people like this point
i said look i don't really trust the
market but if you really gotta get get
in let's use a
very good example you really got again i
like nike okay and
nike at the moment was at 118. and then
it fell to 115
i it was at an all-time high at 1 18
today now it's 115
and i would tell people okay this is it
buy let's say you want to buy 200 shares
of nike
buy 50. now people want to go all in
they want to buy
i want to get started in crypto by
buying the equivalent of
50 nike okay so the person i deal with
well the first thing i'm going to say is
do i need to be insured
do i need to have i mean you know i can
buy insurance
uh that might when i say insurance what
i mean is that it won't vanish
yep because that's what one of the
reasons why i'm afraid to recommend it
so i keep thinking it's gonna
vanish so here's if you're really really
worried and that scares the hell and
you're the most conservative person in
the world
you can literally go by gbtc now gbtc is
that ticker that just has the bitcoin
exposure
there's some premium to it right what i
would tell people is if you're an
accredited investor
you can actually go and participate in
the uh
private placement of gbtc so you can go
to grayscale and say hey i don't want to
buy this
stock publicly i want to invest in a
private placement you got to hold it for
six months illiquid
right but at the end of six months you
still have the same price risk of
bitcoin but now you capture the premium
rather than pay for the premium okay so
there's a little bit of premium
harvesters for owning it all right i
think is the best thing to do
i think that if i'm gonna go in here's
what i'm thinking
i immediately get comfort with that
grace why do i get complacent
track of course i know
that if you really uh want to own gold
you
buy gold bullion so i figure if i want
to own bitcoin
i should go buy bitcoin i mean to me the
analog works
yeah it does and the other thing you
were talking about was basically dollar
cost averaging so here's our crazy stat
for you which is
uh in december of 2017 bitcoin hit 20
000
right it fell from 18 until today it's
now around
11 000 let's call it but if you dollar
cost averaged
every single month the same amount of
money from the high
all the way till today you would be up
double-digit percentages on your
investment
okay well that's how i do things i mean
i tend to either do it
when i was used to be able to be much
more active i would do it every month
i'd invest every month
and then if the market fell between 10
and 15 i would double up that month okay
um that's the plan i would have for
bitcoin now i i always
am afraid that the broker will say oh my
god here comes kramer again
every single month he's do it but you
know what i shouldn't worry about that
right
i mean i shouldn't let that deter me
from buying a smaller amount to get
started
because i i'm not going to use the word
i'm afraid i want to use the word that i
want to get my feet wet
yep i think that's perfectly fair and
and the whole thing here right is
as you know uh if you want to educate
yourself the best thing to do is put
skin in the game
because you'll start paying attention i
always tell people look
before you i mean i want you to do paper
portfolio but we've already passed that
face cause i've watched this
but i tell people look um i don't want
you
let's say you like test okay all right
buy 10 shares of tesla they say no
i got to be big no i need you to
feel like if it goes down you can buy
more
not if it goes down i have to sell and
that
is something that's the buy high so low
for this
um what would i have let's say today
when i have a conversation
and i the one let's just use uh let's
use ten thousand dollars
okay let's just pick that quote so i say
i want to buy ten thousand dollars with
bitcoin yeah you could go do that
really of course you said listen i want
to journal
the 10 000 from my cash account uh to
bitcoin
of course you basically you just got to
determine do you want to buy it through
fidelity do you want to buy it on one of
these exchanges you know what whatever
wherever you want to normally buy it
because that's where my assets are so my
kids understand
now look i i apologize for my lack of of
knowledge but let me just tell you
you're doing a great job
well you know i got to be you know i got
plenty an open hand the fact that i've
been a gold bug all my life
has made me feel very comfortable as
someone who does who likes alternative
assets okay
the fact that my wife did the real
estate part of her portfolio is again
that's the inflation hedge
uh when i saw that you wanted to talk
with me
i said to myself okay why don't i just
be naked
and just say i don't know in the same
way that i went to the apple store the
first time i bought the app i went in
there was this fabulous guy uh it's a
short hill small
i said listen i don't know anything
about apple i it showed me everything
and he said what do you know i said no i
don't know anything
and you know there was a guy next there
was a kid that's like oh my god what an
idiot this guy is
i'm not afraid of being an idiot the
only way to start
if you're an idiot is small and then you
get educated and you become a rookie and
then you become you know
second and third year because i am
convinced
that my kids uh will think that i'm
negligent there was actually a little
dispute between them like i said listen
uh personal inheritance that my dad left
i was very nervous because to the
president candidly because
i think he's a little erratic we may
disagree on that but
we're disagree i mean wow he's a little
radical so i did not
put as much money that my father would
have liked into the kid's account
uh as stock for begin mutual funds
and i now feel i got a chance for
bitcoin because i'm not buying it at 20
000.
of course look it it's a thing where if
i'm right
in the macro environment serves as the
tailwind and if i'm right that
supply and demand economics are going to
remain valid meaning that that bitcoin
having
is going to have a supply shock right
and you as demand increases price has to
go up
then bitcoin is likely to be the best
performing asset in people's portfolio
it's just it's only a 200 billion dollar
asset right so it's so small in the
global financial system
that of course if some you know billion
dollars of capital inflow to bitcoin
versus gold versus equities
you're gonna get way more movement on
bitcoin because it's a smaller asset
class right
and so i think that's a key piece of
this is it feels like everyone's been
talking about bitcoin for years
but it's still pretty small like the the
world hasn't started to really kind of
move assets there i think that this
macro environment
you know i joke and say the federal
reserve ran a three trillion dollar
marketing campaign for bitcoin
right and so it's like people are
starting to pay attention
again but before what happened before
with the pandemic
i would have had a nice conversation
about that bitcoin's kind of interesting
and yeah it's not for me
i think that what really changed my mind
was my daughter uh my 26 year old saying
hey dad
how are we going to pay for 3 trillion
you know but it was one of those
questions it wasn't like
how are we going to pay for the return i
was like no dad how
are we going to pay and i looked at her
and i said
well we're gonna have to raise taxes but
dad what are you gonna
there's not enough money if you raise
taxes so what happens
and i said well we don't know what
happens and she goes but dad you're the
guy
and i said i i'm not the guy i
i i have an idea which is not a good
idea
about what will happen which is bad and
she said well what can i do and that's
when i said listen we're gonna
get your house get you some gold uh and
i did i got in the beach house i mean
all these are designed
for what i regard not it's not gonna be
apocalypse it's just gonna be not good
yeah and i wanna hedge against not good
i need
i expect that there's gonna be global
warming and i expected if i bought a
house
right on the beach it's fast so we
bought the house five houses here okay
that was the hedge against yeah it's
ocean grove it's nice
um that was the hedge against what's
going to happen up but
that's an illiquid asset that has
i think a residential risk uh
particularly if things
get ugly okay uh which i think is a
perfectly read before i wouldn't say i
said what are you crazy i mean the march
of progress
but progress stopped uh and this is a
very serious issue and that
did the truly three trillion so i got to
take action
and i'm gonna take action after this
video the uh my favorite
stats are for the last six fiscal years
the government has set a new record for
federal tax income
revenue right so we keep taking in more
and more money
but the intra-year deficit gets bigger
and bigger
so it's not it's not a it's not an
income problem right it's just
we just keep spending more and more and
more and more and people will debate you
know what should we spend on what should
we not i don't care
all i know is that when you print that
much money i'll tell you where it comes
from
they're going to steal the purchasing
power of all the people holding cash
yeah i i told my daughter to read about
buy more
the weimar republic uh read about what
happened before the third right
how they wiped out uh purchasing power
and then they wiped out savings
there's a one-two punch uh everyone was
painting lists one of the big reasons
why
you had the tumultuous and i'm not
saying it's going to happen but yeah the
tumultuous things that happened in
germany
had a lot to do with them printing money
the way we printed
they were walking around with
wheelbarrows i hope that doesn't happen
but as a student of history
uh i'm ashamed that i have not acted on
what is the first time that i've seen
a weimar mar-like situation in our
country and i believe in
2011 with the uh i spoke to the fellow
eagles when they just
just had just downgraded the dead and i
said listen you don't have to worry
we're the strongest country in the world
blah blah blah now it doesn't have to do
with whether the strongest country
what it has to do with is we can't pay
we just can't
so what do you do now you can go
overseas i mean that's not
my plan yep uh or you can hedge
and of course uh heads with i've got the
hedge on one side
but i don't have appreciation of hitch
and that's why i got to make this move
which is why i'm glad i talk with you
because
for the most part i'm stuck i'm a stock
guy i know that i'm a gold guy i'm a
real estate guy because my wife
um but i didn't have anyone to talk to
and the reason i have anyone to talk to
is because
um of the of what i call the portnoy
factor which is that is everybody to
speculate
and i'm thinking about 10 years because
i'm thinking about when i mean
my kids will not the moment i make that
move my kids will not be able to touch
this
until 23rd okay of course so i
i that's i'm certainly not trading i and
i'm gonna buy it in state just because i
don't want to commit all one level but
you know if you know you're not gonna be
able to touch something in 2030
and it's cash well believe me that cash
is not going to be worth what you think
is and i am
i'd like to think i'm a pro uh i'd like
to think that i have
analyzed the situation but the three
trillion dollars that we printed changed
everything that i believe in and now if
you told me honest to god if you told me
that i should be buying
lakes in maine because they're i would
do i mean i'm so
i am so concerned i'm not frightened i'm
not scared but i'm concerned
that i'm not being proof and i now think
that
bitcoin is proof when when we get off
i'm gonna tweet to everyone and tell
them to send you the best memes that
they have to welcome you to bitcoin and
you'll be very impressed with the meme
ability
but also i'm not walking around with if
i walked around with gold in my pocket
you said welcome me
i would like i'd hide under the rug
because then everyone knows i'm walking
around
he must have gold coins sewn into his
jacket you know
like this is one that obviously um it's
not going to be stolen it'll be it'll be
i don't i don't mean to push fidelity
but my money's been with fidelity since
1977 so that's i have a long history
uh but what it tells me is that uh
when the inevitable happens to me it
will not be like
it disappeared exactly where the rest of
the stuff is
uh and that my kids will
feel that it's like cash but better
absolutely before i let you go i ask
everyone the same two questions first
ones
what's the most important book you've
ever read uh anna karenina
uh because yeah uh tolstoy because it
really is
about about love um
and about uh health and about tragedy
and about how sadly life doesn't work
life does not work out and that's other
than for levin
that's what that story is about and i
want people to read it because
many people think that the young people
think that life works out and they need
to have a
wake-up call that it doesn't and no one
writes it better than tolstoy tulsa's my
favorite writer
that's a great suggestion uh second
one's more fun
aliens believer or non-believer
uh can i say ghosts
you are the second person you're the
second person to say you believe in
ghosts but not aliens
votes my um my scoring up and then i
know we got just stuff to do
my cousin you know i never met him was
deceased
but my cousin was a was a a pilot he was
a bomber pilot
uh and he went it was uh
he flew in the great raid of over
hamburg
and he was shot down it was the
hamburglar you couldn't there were so
many planes it was dark
he got shot down and he died and my
grandma
told me that there was a picture of him
on the piano had been there the whole
time for the whole war
and when she came home it had fallen
and that it's impossible to rationalize
and i say no it is it was a ghost
now you can say well jim you're
absolutely nuts but why did it fall
i go to a uh
my mom and i my mom loved this place
called the gritty pals
uh in venice and
that we ended up getting the same room
and i swear i saw her in the mirror
big nerd i swear sword and my kids do
too
and i genuinely believe in ghosts uh
now i don't believe it goes to the point
where like gay you know when your past
you get three ghosts
i just can't rationalize certain things
uh other than to believe that they're
ghosts so i mean experience
certainly ghosts all right that's
personal experience can't say anything
wrong with that
listen thank you so much for doing this
ladies and gentlemen mr jim kramer
himself
thank you pop